okay enough of this sad [ __ ] roll you're
right
you know hug or something I'm sorry I'm
opening around lefties I got some real
ooh the 13 right now man this is go to
the back Medicaid
we'll talk about it we don't have to
talk about it whatever you want to do
bring a broom sweep it up back let's go
small thank you
it's just what the doctor ordered don't
take me man thank you the 13th hey you
know that woman that came in yesterday
yeah man what happened yesterday man you
left me all alone and got busy
don't forget man you're still new here
no I'm sorry bro I had my girlfriend
that was your girlfriend yeah you just
moved to a honey man you work faster huh
oh man I wish my girlfriend from the bay
she's kind of tall yeah kind of scary
yeah she's kind of a bully too man yeah
kinda I met her in eighth grade
some kids were making fun of her high I
stood up for that day she told me I was
her new boyfriend and it's kind of been
that way ever since
she never laughs man how can I be with
someone who never laughs so when the
shop was raided my boss asked who wants
to go down to La shop I just volunteered
I didn't even say goodbye to work so he
just left without saying goodbye
yeah and that's [ __ ] up man you know
what that feels like man what time I
came back to his job after a two-week
sick leave and he [ __ ] left man I had
no job I was sick man no you know what I
mean not to have closure
she's just wonder what the [ __ ] happened
I had a suppression of come over here
girl of both told her I wanted to break
up and I told her I couldn't be with a
long-distance relationship I was in a
long-distance relationship well I called
a long-distance she called her
restraining order how does she take it
she's moving in next week Wow that you
took it good kinda
what you